peu
la france tout entière à célébrer le
souvenir de jeanne d'arc en arrive là
des pyramides c'est d'abord l'hommage de
monsieur de brienon qui au nom du
maréchal pétain vient déposer une
couronne de fleurs au pied de la statue
de l'héroïne
c'est ensuite le défilé de la légion
populaire
[Musique]
orléans en présence de monsieur le
préfet du loiret et monseigneur coucou a
lieue l'inauguration du cours des
tourelles qui reprend son ancienne
dénomination ce pour sur l'ordre de la
municipalité juive dans les eaux avait
été baptisé pont george ça ici à cet
emplacement même jeanne d'arc le 7 mai
14 129 réussissait à prendre des tours
d'avancé première défense anglaise
contre les troupes de france à l'appel
du maréchal toute la jeunesse de france
participe aux cérémonies à rouen où les
anglais ont brûlé jeanne les jeunes
célèbre la mémoire de celle qui sauva
l'unité de la france
il y a plus de cinq siècles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à paris place saint-augustin les
délégations des centres de jeunesse sont
venus fleurir la statue de jeanne
pendant qu'alain zenner dans tous les
centres a été lu un message du
secrétaire général de la jeunesse
[Musique]
a paris encore au cours d'un spectacle
organisé par le rassemblement national
populaire monsieur marcel déat prend la
parole
copé dans l'esprit et dans le coeur une
grande idée celle de la chrétienté et
nous devons savoir dans l'esprit et dans
le coeur une grande idée seul de
l'europe qui est à construire
[Musique]